um my name is Diego Ungaro I was
actually a student here up until
14 working with John osterhout and now
I'm out in the real world but still
doing the same type of thing as so this
talks on runway and you tool that I've
built an open-sourced so first I'll get
into why I think we need new tools for
distributed system design and I'll give
you an overview of runway and do some
demos in runway and then come back and
talk a little bit more about how you
would get and build a runway model
yourself you I think we have a lot of
time today so feel free to interrupt me
if you have questions comments I does
anyone disagree that distributed systems
are hard so there's a number of reasons
why they're difficult for humans to
think about so there's concurrency you
know machines are they're operating in
parallel door sending messages to each
other by the time you receive a message
it's already stale the content it's
reflecting happened a while ago due to
network latency you have to deal with
failures but you also have to do with
failures that happened during failures
you know you can't just put a try-catch
block and be done with it they will come
at inconvenient times i D events you
know you can write out the good case
events in your system but then when you
start injecting delays and failures
there's so many possible in her leavings
of what can happen it's really hard to
predict and then because these things
are running across the network we
usually have little disability into
what's going on and poor debugging
environments you know you try to drop
into gdb and suddenly there's time outs
and your failure detector fires and good
luck
ah so in this talk I'm going to use a
lot of examples from raft raft is a
consensus algorithm it was my PhD topic
how many people here already familiar
with reft about half the room cool so
you don't need to know all the details
but you do need to know it it's split
into two phases first the raft cluster
will elect a leader and and then it'll
get that leader to replicate its log to
the other servers in the cluster hi and
yeah it's it's very big enough system to
have very complicated bugs in it here's
one that David mascaras found it
involves the top service leader crashes
the bottom River becomes leader crashes
tops over it becomes leader again
replicates things out a little bit more
crashes and that's the scenario and then
the bottom forever becomes leader again
and it took all that to show the bugs so
you really can't think one failure deep
you have to think about the entire state
space so what what do we do an industry
or even I okay fine and in academia you
get to do proofs sometimes but in
industry we kind of rely on these things
on the left to find flaws we lean on
code reviews where hopefully some human
is just going to look at the code and
spot it right or unit tests or
randomized testing we have a lot of
approaches to find implementation bugs
but they're going to find localized bugs
you know the code you had in your head
isn't what you wrote down in your editor
you read a test you find it you fix it
great like you really don't want to find
a design error at this stage right a
designer you know at this point you've
already written production code it's
expensive to change you might have to
change quite a bit of stuff
this is not good you want to find your
design sooner and then of course you can
go and do all these things approaches
for figuring out the local asked bugs so
what do we do in the design phase if we
really wanted to do this well I think
we'd have goals around communication
goals around evaluating our design if we
want to we want to communicate clearly
about that design unambiguously we want
to build intuition we want the design to
be reviewable so something that you know
someone can take offline point at I
think through you want to discuss the
issues consider alternatives and then
you'd want to evaluate the design before
you actually build the production code
so is it simple enough otherwise it
won't work is it correct is it is it
fast is it available is it scalable
these are all things we should be doing
in the design phase but what we actually
do in the design phase today we we've
got whiteboards got back in the envelope
calculations maybe we write a design
duck in plain English Andy was
suggesting earlier that alcohol is a
commonly used tool today but it's not
really going to help um so these things
don't quite meet our goals right they
might start to build the intuition but
we're still just writing code before we
know whether it's a good idea well if we
could be doing these other things we
could be visualizing our designs we
could be specifying them and model
checking if you have time sure to
approve we could be running simulations
to figure out if they're going to be
fast enough little-scale and we're not
and runway hopes to change that
so runways built around the concept of a
system model and a model is that just a
representation of a system that captures
force essential components and emits a
real event details so here here we've
got a model of raft and it's simplified
in that the network is flat you know
these machines just send messages to
each other on a flat network there's no
processing time they don't write to disk
you know but but we are watching the
core state variables in the protocol
over here we've got the logs and when
you're thinking about log replication
and raft it's really nice to have those
lined up like that so runway is tries to
combine these things into one tool I and
and all of these benefit from a small
model so if you tried to visualize a
production system it's too complex right
you can't put all that on the screen you
can't review a specification that that's
that's so large and you your model
checker is probably not going to
terminate in time um and by the time you
just take the essence of your system you
can run a simulation and you know under
certain assumptions you can start to
feel pretty confident about it okay so
what is runway actually do you feed it a
model file and from that you can run
your model files serves as your
specification but it's also executable
so runway can run that through a
randomized simulator and produce an
execution or a history of things like
server to received a message service
reprocessed 141 sent one and then from
that execution we can actually visualize
that so we can take it on the screen and
animate it we could also interact with
the visualization to alter the execution
that we have
another thing we can do if we run that
execution for long enough or run a bunch
of these if we can build up data about
our design and then graph that and if we
want to drill in we can go back to the
visualization or we can take that same
spec and run it through a model checker
so now we're looking for is there any
possible way this design would enter a
state that is known to be bad and by the
way if there is then that error is an
execution that we can go up and look at
instead of digging through log files so
the hope is if we put all this into one
tool we can write one model and get many
benefits from it and maybe that's
practical enough to use in industry so
let me do a couple of demos now starting
with the too many bananas problem if you
want to follow along at home this is
live at runway dot systems so the too
many bananas problem goes like this
you've got a few people in a house and
occasionally one of them will get hungry
and when they get hungry they can eat a
banana and they're happy again okay next
person might get hungry eats a banana
they're happy again if you run out of
bananas I you've got to go to the store
and up well that we got unlucky the
store didn't provide any bananas but
usually you go to the store you can
bring back a bunch of bananas and then
eat one and be happy again um so problem
with bananas as you all know they go bad
over time they spoil so I in this model
we don't ever want to have more than
eight bananas at the house at any given
time and if I just run this through a
randomized semi
later we probably see an example where
we'll end up with too many so a lot of
people get hungry got multiple people
out at the store there we go so what
happened there we can back up in time so
basically the house was out of bananas
everyone was hungry and then multiple
people started heading to the store so
pretty much everyone went to the store
they started bringing back bananas no
coordination between themselves and they
ended up with 10 bananas very wasteful
so if I go to the correct version of the
problem we can run this for a long time
and it will never hit a bug and my fix
is when I when you go to the store you
now leave a note on the house that first
gone to store and that prevents anyone
else from heading out to the store okay
I'm pretty confident this works so
that's it that's a simple problem simple
enough that I can show you the the
entire code for that in a couple minutes
but let me show you a couple other
models first so this one is an elevator
system it's a nine-story building these
are people on the right that little Z
means are sleeping or a numbers where
they want to go and the dot indicates
where the elevator is going to stop so
this elevator is heading two four seven
and eight unloading a passenger cool
you're familiar with elevators here
so I can let's see I can kind of hover
over lease and I can I can figure out oh
this person is currently riding an
elevator and see all this information
about it this person's waiting there
trying to get 43 I can also get all that
information down here for free so this
is the entire state of our system we've
got people as that top array floor
controls is the little lights at the
floor whether they're lit up or not and
each elevators at between a full or at a
floor my habits doors opening etc so
over here I'm I've got a graph that's
being built up of all the elevator rides
that are happening and I can run a
simulation in the background using web
workers where you know a lot of elevator
ride for taking place I'm waiting for a
bad one it's bad but it's not terrible
that's pretty good
so now I can take that and click on it
and try to figure out well why was this
ride so bad in this case they spent
quite a bit of time waiting for an
elevator and then quite a bit of time
writing it so when I click on that bar
it's actually moved the timeline over to
the start of that ride highlighted the
elevator that took so long and
highlighted that person up there on the
on the eighth floor that's waiting for
an elevator to arrive and now we can
just watch it and see what while i was
just so painful the doors open the next
time how to drop someone off and then
turn around and pick something up so
that wasn't too bad and now one stop two
stops three stops for stops to go five
floors is kind of embarrassing um fig
imagine how you use this with a
distributed system to and and of course
I have I have a model if raft here so
over here we've got five servers on a
raft cluster that's little time outs on
the circumference and server three is
about to time out and it starts an
election so did river too but server 31
leadership and so now that's reverse the
leader and it's it's sending out
heartbeats back and forth to keep
everyone else happy so it's the same
idea right we have all the servers are
shown here and of course the leader has
a lot more information because it has
more work to do folks it's basically
tracking information for each of the
other favors
down here we have messages in the
network so yeah heart beats being sent
out the response is coming back and then
they disappear and I can actually
interact with this so I can I can shut
down our leader hi which forks the
timeline so now now we're in kind of a
parallel world I can submit a couple
client requests and and this new leader
is going to replicate those out yeah so
I mean I can basically interact with a a
full implementation of raft that just
doesn't have all the things you need for
a production system right it is just a
model but it I it does show that the
protocol does what it's not to do yeah
so I couldn't pursue my could replay
okay yeah you can somewhere down here I
think you can actually download a a log
file with everything that's happened and
send it to someone else and not that I
can I replay it to rub the bugs off
something serious happened well the
exact same sequence over it was a shame
arbitrary decisions yeah with the same
sequence of operation I know that that
would be cool it's not something it can
do today but poor request would be
welcome so for one issue is like raft of
generating random numbers for all these
timeouts all the time and you'd have to
probably put a seat on that and then
maybe you wouldn't be able to change the
number of times you get a random number
there's another trick you coulda just
talked about sweet okay oh yeah another
thing we can do is drop a message and
see how that behaves I mean this cool
you get you get a lot more control here
than you would in a in a running system
so let me let me restart this is a
little janky another thing I can do I
could flip this bit that basically says
anytime a leader establishments itself
we're going to restart and host another
leader election make sure that's working
so server for became later we restart
and and we can basically do the same
thing with we did with the elevators
only now its leader elections instead so
we're running a bunch of elections in
the background and they're all taking
about you know 142 180 milliseconds but
every now and then we'll see a split
vote like that yeah that's the case I
want to repeat so I can find out well so
we can repeat it we just can't change
the code and then repeat it not me now
that we're over and over again to see
what caused that bad sequence so now so
we can watch that
so I bet yeah it looks like silver once
over 2 and silver 3 will time out at
just about the same time here and they
need a majority of the votes in the
cluster so they need three votes to
become leader it's going to be really
difficult for them
nobody got all three votes and then reft
just the simplest thing if just wait
around for another timeout
so that was that was our slow election
and questions okay so um I know I know
that wasn't like terribly impressive
it's it's still really early on the
project and take a bit more of a proof
of concept than anything but it is
already showing some value right and if
we compare this to to what I did for
raft for my PhD it was well write the
production-ready code almost
production-ready fine it took me a few
months after graduating to get it into
production and then you know right the
TLA plus back so this is specification
and also add did some model checking
with it write a write a visualization in
JavaScript so writing basically the same
thing different language I write a
simulator and rust to explore a whole
bunch of leader election variations and
then write pseudocode to present this
compactly for other people to read it
there's no way that one's correct
because it's never been run but
basically you know wrote it four times
over this pretty much the same thing so
if and of course if I change anything
now I have to go back and revise all
these do I hope not too so what's runway
if that tool existed at the time like
maybe I could have written one model and
gotten the same value out of all of it
and in my experience the more things you
do with a piece of code the more you're
you're gonna iron out the bugs and flesh
it out so it's it just would have been a
better experience over
all right the other thing is all these
other things benefit from visualization
so if if I'm trying to debug an issue
with my spec it's really nice if I can
just see it behave visually because when
you know when I server does something
it's not supposed to do you just
naturally spot it that way I guess I
don't know it's just wired into our
brains okay so so what does it mean how
do I build a runway model today so you
need to produce a specification file and
a view file the spec is in it main
specific language that runway interprets
and I'll get into that in a minute the
view is just off the shelf web stuff so
I tend to use JavaScript d3d 30 library
that helps with drawing and animating
things and then SVG for what I'm
actually manipulating on the screen so
the view file in the spec file date in
my experience they tend to be about the
same size but the view file is totally
boring code that you should never look
at it's it's got a job it's supposed to
take the state and draw it on the screen
but you won't really learn anything from
spending time on that code whereas the
spec like ideally this is what you'd be
sharing with your team makes to to Duke
design reviews so what I've suggest you
do is start start with a sketch of what
it is you want your visualization to
look like because that's going to help
you tease out like what is the core
state in my system and then you can kind
of define that so the specification
models strongly-typed so you can define
all those types and your state variables
and start to create the view since I
said the
once you've got the visualization that
helps you with debugging if you if
you've got the wrong transition rules
after that you can probably spot them
and and then you can fill in your and
variant some transition rules one tip
like with raft you've got leader
election and then you've got log
replication if you're working on the log
replication stuff you you can just set
an initial state where I don't know if
everyone is the leader already so you
don't have to go through a leader
election every time so as I said the
specification is executable code but
it's it's not you know you run it
through runway it's not not it is
touring complete it's not a
general-purpose programming language so
you define all the state you define this
so you define types you define state
variables and a starting state I a set
of transition rules and then invariance
that you want to hold so properties on
the state that should be true before and
after applying every rule it's called a
labeled transition system it's similar
to a state machine ah and and so you
want to include in your transition rules
not only the behavior that your system
is supposed to have but also the things
that you want to go wrong in the model
so like in the raft model a server can
stop and then restart and a message can
be dropped or duplicated and delayed and
and the way execution works is I
applying the rule is atomic and it
runway will do one at a time so take the
starting state apply a rule apply a rule
apply a rule if multiple rules are
active then depending on if you're
running the simulator it's just going to
make a random choice and
if you're running the model checker it's
going to explore all pabs that that's a
very restrictive programming model it
suits the JavaScript model i mean it's
it's commuting it's a head loop based
because the rule is atomic that means
there's no interference of something
else happening while the rules right so
yes so what that means is you if you
want to permit concurrency in your model
you have to write small rules that you
know do it take a step and then return
and then sometime later they'll take the
next step but the benefit is now i'm not
writing i can model a concurrent system
but i'm not writing concurrent code so i
don't need mutexes I don't need any
explicit synchronization it it works
pretty well for distributed systems from
that in my experience I don't know how
well it worked for like very low level
systems code one of the common errors is
starting to process a second message
value processing the first one that's a
very common error and distributed system
you mess up your state you can never
tell what happened because you never get
that exact sequence again fair I what
one other interesting yep this is suited
for a particular class of distributed
systems and and rules
good question so this is the way that
more or less that's the way that all
distributed protocols are modeled in the
literature a distributed system such as
your body in system you cannot have a
single thread of rules that does system
stitch where you can so the important
thing is since there's no shared state
in a distributed system we're
communicating over messages if two
flippers do something concurrently and
then try to tell each other about it
it's equivalent to one took an action
the next took an action and then they
sent their messages right and and that's
why this is the model is sufficient for
a lot of a lot of academic literature
but I don't ever think about human
bodies and and you know I we have how
many cells other servers yep
oh okay well let's get a bit more
concrete by looking at some of the code
so this is a too many bananas problem we
declared variable for the number of
bananas I and this is a correct version
so we need a boolean to represent
whether there's a note stuck on the
house or not then we've got our people
so room makes us an array person index
from one to five and each person is
either happy hungry going to the store
or returning from the store so it's
similar to an enum except the different
options can carry data so when you're
when you're returning from the store
there's how many bananas are you coming
back with and so the the compiler will
check that statical you're only allowed
to access caring if you are in the state
returning from store we'll check against
the assertion on the maximum number
bananas that it'll do at run time in
between every rule no no I just say
returning from store carrying zero to
ten and now it's not that smart because
model errors that's a typical kind of
model error anytime a number shows up in
two places or a condition shows up in
two places you're often going to get
them different and ice that the compiler
check that too I and this just has one
rule but it's a it's a multi-part rule
depending on what state you're in so for
for each of the roommates so taking each
one individually I if they're happy they
can become hungry and that would be an
atomic state change and then we break
out of the match statement and return
out of the rule return control
and then the system would be able to
reevaluate if they're hungry and there's
no bananas at home but there's a note at
the front of the house well we said
they're not supposed to leave for the
store because one of the roommates
already gone for the store so they just
they do nothing and they so they fall
out of the if statement so I fell out of
the match statements and they didn't
change any of the state in the model and
so I you know the the interpreter will
look at that and say okay well this
person is inactive until any of the
variables that it read changed so if
it's state changes if the number of
bananas change if that note goes away
then we'll reevaluate this person until
then they're not interesting if there
was no note present they could set one
and head out to the store I do that
atomically or if there were bananas at
home they can eat one and become happy
oh so you're going to the store they can
come back with a random number of
bananas between 0 and 8 and when they're
coming back they add what they're
carrying to the bananas at home remove
the note and go back to hungry and
probably what they're going to do next
is eat a banana but this model permits
the case where you go to the store you
bring back bananas and your roommate
eats them all before you get a chance it
can happen I said that Paul's gonna hate
me
the fluid for you Paul so for what about
time right the bananas problem is kind
of asynchronous doesn't care about time
but in raft time times really important
when you're asking about how long leader
election takes so the way computer
scientists like to think about this if
each server tries to approximate the
global clock the one that's out there in
the sky that we synchronize 21 at the
root of the NTP hierarchy and this is
this we've got one here you can talk to
will and they will correct us and the
reminder that no in fact we've got
relativity and all these other things
and whatever the point is up we we need
time we we need to think about time in
our systems and we want some of the
properties like in reft we want it to
rep cannot just corrupt state because
the clocks drift or have skew we want
some properties to hold no matter if we
spend a long time processing something
or a message gets delayed and yeah other
times if we're talking about
availability of performance like we
absolutely need a watch to measure
against because these are rates over
time so so runway takes a pretty simple
approach right now which is if you're
running in the simulator then this past
function will consult a global clock and
if you're running in in the model
checker asynchronously past function
will return true so to give an example
and raft once once you're once you get
through your randomized timeout you're
supposed to start a new election so you
know we've got this rule start need
election that's defined over all of the
different servers and if we're in the
simulator then this is just going to
refer to a global clock it's a global
variable that just you know happens to
be globally synchronized if we're model
checking on the other hand this just
always returns true so any server can
just timeout at any time and that's what
lets us check some of the safety
properties so that it would be very
useful to be able to assign a different
clock each node and allow and allow for
different drips because again when
you're using timeouts a lot of trouble
appears from clock errors yep and that
yep that's one that we should do with
raft of the timeouts are randomized so
it just it you kind of get that anyway
randomized I every time server generates
nu time about it my bus is over an
excuse I'm exhibit um but but yet i
think i think you're right that we do
need to bake something in the language
for this will be useful to inject clock
false well and then and that you can do
as a rule you should avoid the past so i
can certainly define a rule that if this
servers offset from the global clock is
now radically different from what it
just was um like a little bit block is
part of their part of the system then so
i could do the drill hmm yeah I'd I
don't I don't like I don't have enough
examples where it has it hasn't worked
I'm some kind of not sure what the best
thing here is happy to chat Paul doesn't
think I'm being critical I'm not at all
in this great awesome
um okay for two to wrap up here I argued
that we should be applying neat you know
tools to help us design our distributed
systems beyond the whiteboard and
alcohol models are you know whatever
this is it should be based on modeling
because it helps focus our attention on
the things that matter and leaves out
unimportant details like memory
allocation or whatever so runway
combines specification model checking
simulation and visualization into one
tool and the hope is that even though
like most of the time we couldn't
justify doing these things independently
if we pack it into one tool maybe
there's enough value there to make it
worthwhile so you can go check out the
models build your own this is all open
source so help develop runway I and you
know let's solve problems at the design
phase so it's it's JavaScript right now
and that's mainly for the visualization
part when it comes to model checking I
I'm not want I'm not going to stand up
here and tell you that javascript is the
right language for that but I think we
should probably be compiling down to an
existing model checker that does Lexus a
lot of times the difficulties only a
period scale so how large your system
connected I don't know I so you know the
the runtimes not very efficient dits an
interpreter right now we should probably
switch over to a compiler instead
there's your browser can do quite a bit
but it's it's definitely limited I
probably terrible I don't know I've
never checked
and and it's also going to depend on
like some of the you know these things
down here we could just turn turn off if
they're like this is storing the
complete state of of every step you take
it's amazing how much you can get away
was just doing anyway ah and then the
visualizations can get arbitrarily
complex like here's a here's one I like
to show because I don't understand it at
all scad David did it so I think he's
modeling a financial system that's like
most of my understanding here so you can
and i'm not sure why but you can drag
around the biggest crap fine we get that
back i'll come on I mean that that's how
it went there but anyhow I can on some
of these I can make a request and then
it's oh did you see that it's a sending
messages back and forth if it's doing
fairly complex things I i if we just had
little rectangles that might scale a
whole lot better but um yeah I don't
know haven't pushed it it's example
nothing my question is there's kind of
two lobes to the two rows run
concurrently
I mean I i really wish i could move it
uh yeah yeah so um down here it make we
can see the code and it's a it's
actually syntax highlighted even uh and
david wrote a giant explanation of what
this is maybe we can just figure it out
if we have a bunch of time request races
so intermediate nodes active relay
stations by receiving a message press in
it to spark should probably take this
out fine huh so the general approach
that you're taking i actually very
impressed with it similar to delivery
lamppost plea for us to be writing
specifications before we write code you
know his notion that that bridges don't
pull down the software systems do man
does because bridges have Architects
designed it before they build it so i
think there's a there's a lot here that
is the right direction to go in and
clearly this is a basic tool but I think
he's headed in the right direction in
many different ways and I think of them
kind of things that can go wrong at
scale in large systems are feeling you
know right on its power law distribution
of things that can go around with things
near the access the most likely and
things further down the access this
likely the things at the front we can
deal with wikas I we can do possibly
dead a power supply is redundant fists
you know we don't know plans you know to
make sure that was pale but then we
don't know how things are going to break
so we're going to put it in practice and
we get it to production and then we face
it when we find things that go wrong
column is the area in the long tail is
bigger than everything else up front and
the only way you can deal
the long tail is by being more formal
about you model about your verification
and about more disciplined about world
buildings so i think that the gift given
us here ungaro is that Diego saw his
potato is it's a potato cutter potato
gnocchi keep you're getting is the gives
you giving us here is this some
collision that we really want to scare
our systems despite the fact that Serb
you later may need some work to make it
scale oui oui the systems in practice
you can't you can't go through enough of
the things that can go wrong to really
protect yourself from the random
failures that were carrying the long
tail I throw a lot ideas in there um so
first ad on t la plus and Leslie Lamport
for this is definitely all influenced by
that and I I used to la plus for raft
and in part this is just making it more
accessible but it's yeah I mean I like
you are doing model check when you can
follow it there is a placeholder that
technically does model checking it's not
efficient then again neither to la plus
quickie I mean you have a programming
language yeah it's neat a debugger right
um so on Paul's point about scaling I
think yeah I think there are I mean we
talked about these systems that scale to
thousands of servers a lot of them are
actually organized into small groups of
a handful and and they would fit this
quite nicely and if you can show and you
can convince yourself that it works in
all cases and then that gets rid of your
tail but of course there's there's all
the unanticipated problems the things
with highly unlikely probability that
you encounter only after so many machine
hours and this can't help you there but
the like there you know random bit flip
but this should help save the deadlock
detection Yeah right should the model
checker should tell me I have a
potential deadlock before him and run it
yes um I'm curious it you've used it to
his fon gods and systems who produced uh
so far so you want at a point yet so the
only the only example I've got is uh so
I was helping at it a team we were
sitting around white boards for three
days and then on the fourth day I went
off and wrote a model of it what at the
very end of that third day we took a
picture of the board and then we kept
talking a little bit and discovered a
bug but it didn't ah sweet we updated
the board but didn't take a new picture
on the fourth day I was going by the
picture I had forgotten about that bug
and the model checker found it again so
almost that and that was that concurrent
not distributed system used in a parlor
version of this that can be deployed on
AWS from which I had to scale simulation
uh I mean there's only so much you can
as a human there's only so much visual
input you can take in if you're just
trying to collect data like if I wanted
to know over a billion runs a raft
leader election what's the performance
sure Oh what is conditions how often do
they know being a biblical there's a
condition occur that you can you put
watchers on it that's what you do want
to even when you're debugging a single
system put a water I things and let the
ring burn until it hits the washer
header but the scalability problem you'd
have to make this a distributed system
itself you have to run across a thousand
news yeah then hope those crap
a resilient distributive system well
okay if you lose a few simulations I
don't think it's a big deal great I
think it's absolutely needed and you
know we're all frustrated because you're
beginning not Andy looking for the end
yeah and it's it's difficult I mean if
it's it's a heart it's hard to get
people to shift to adopting this and
doing it early enough for it to have
value so I don't know you know maybe
here in an academic setting where
visualization might be more important
maybe it could get a foothold I've done
something similar but I had a write
JavaScript so I'm writing what this
compiles to basically and that's my
daughter so this would be very nice to
have what i meant for both and what
problem are you modeling distributed
data center cool yep so but I've always
written scripting code as the first
implementation not going directly to
production right exactly the reason you
point out here and say something about
your expedition to rust did he give you
any surprises where the things not you
like also very curious about that yes I
should preface it with the florist
version 0.8 so a while ago now and this
was back when there were a few more
symbols around different pointer types
that you could have that I believe
they're simplified from slant it so for
this so I wrote just what I was
describing a simulator of parallel not
distributed for raft leader election and
I was messing with the algorithm and
seeing how would behave under different
assumptions um I think you know it's
it's
asked it kept me from shooting myself in
the foot a couple of times even though
I've written a lot of C++ it it also I
you know the type system got in the way
a couple places and and it you have to
you have to think about how you'll
design your program to to satisfy the
type checker ahead of time so I think it
it takes some transition period i would
say that i'm just getting into waves of
positive and you prevent you from making
very hard to find errors yeah um no
there's there's some good some bad there
was and I ever said it's improved since
then but there's like you know there's
some patterns like I think at the time
say say you did a for loop to do a
linear search you find the element you
want and then you want to update that
element and break out of the loop I
wouldn't let you do that at the time I
think you can now what I you thrust
again only if I had an excuse to um you
know it it's a fun language I like it a
lot compared to c++ but practically
speaking I don't have an excuse to use
either one right now I have been writing
go code lately okay I'm happy to stick
around with quest to chat or answer
questions but I think that's it
you